foreign
[Music]
Marvel films fail at the box office the
CEO suggests they've cheapened the brand
and let's be honest you probably started
skipping shows entirely now get ready
for a series that proves if it's not
time to scrap the whole thing Disney
should at least pause until their next
batch of Chris is ready
[Music]
generated titles gross Nick Fury is back
from space station and everyone agrees
that he sucks now the one with power the
one with ability the theory is gone he's
traumatized
[Music]
and really effing old these Washington
walks with the limp can barely seal the
good oil the fact
that no tells me all I need to know
about this new rather old Nick Fury why
don't you hobble your ancient ass on out
of here before I have you to finish
traded in the latest sequel that thinks
audiences want to see their Heroes as
pathetic washed up sad sex you want to
get soup
let's get soup after the events of
Captain Marvel a movie you totally
remember the events of right right the
aliens who look like Piccolo's left nut
are still stranded on Earth Fury has
phoned in finding them a new planet I
knew it's been a few years of searching
that that was no other planet out there
for you
and he won't even carve out a chunk of
Norway to crash on now Scrolls have
infiltrated our society to find a
long-term home in the second Marvel show
about how refugees are secretly
terrorists one word
only my own skin home in my own skin
uh-oh the villains are in the ride again
quick do the thing
there was still people in there
she's the only language these people
understand that's better deep State good
strap in for a spy Thriller made
entirely out of spy Thriller cliches
where everyone has to be stupid for the
plot to work last I checked Brody is a
scroll
what and even the scroll stick with one
face to cut down on production costs I'm
gonna try a white guy for a Russian
soldier Okay as Fury and Friends we'll
do anything they can to stop World War
III without calling the Avengers you
can't keep depending on these
superheroes to swoop in and save our
asses because then you have to admit
he's been scraping all their goo into a
cup and hiding in his grave imagine
looking cap in the eye and telling him
you scraped his gew the shame you'd feel
strap in for a show that's about more
than two old guys yelling about
off-screen promises they broke well not
entirely have you lost your reptilian
ass mind hey what would you have done
this ain't about me cause you were gone
you got any more abuse you want to hear
on my way
going for a walk it's also about Emilia
Clarke who co-stars as Gaia because she
can't turn down the chance to learn
another made-up language
she's a scroll terrorist until a couple
days before the finale where she gets
almost every Power in the MCU no way
that's gonna bite Us in the ass later or
uh look cool on camera
also joining the fight as British
spymaster Sonia fallsworth Olivia
Coleman summons hope-like strength to
carry the series on her back armed with
the one comedy bid of saying mean things
in a friendly way I'm very good at being
your bestie I'm also devilishly good at
being not your bestie
well now that's confirmed
let's party shall we if they're not busy
gaslighting you that's threatening you
with murder
that's what all the podcasts are about
ah she's cheeky yeah and old favorites
return like office Tim who's been a
scroll since who gives a Maria Hill
who's bravely sacrificed to give her
boss a little extra Pizzazz Sharon
Carter who no she's not a scroll so she
just randomly turned into an arms dealer
okay and Colonel Rhodes who's revealed
to have been a scroll since at least the
death of Tony Stark and maybe even
earlier honestly they've been hinting
that he's a shapeshifter since day one
so gently massage your temples for a spy
Thriller without any tension about a
hero who thinks humans are full of hate
there's not enough room or Tolerance on
this planet or another species plunges
Earth into a race war
now you got dumbass Vigilantes killing
innocent humans too then dips back into
space with one of the good ones while
we're left to pick up the pieces because
it turns out Nick Fury always has his
eye on the bigger picture when can he
get his next drink
let's drovia I'm pretty sure you
recollect my drink of choices
how about a drink instead I wouldn't say
no I wanted to share my favorite liquid
lunch with you happy van Waco
mmm
[Music]
this is a tasty bourbon
starring
mace winded game of clones double in a
blue suit Kingsley bit adew no no am I
I'm undercover shouldn't this be Julie
Louis Dreyfus spy wife how I met my
maker and most MCU fans at this point I
just told this phase would be over
Invasion of the Body matures
so cool how Fury Keeps The Avengers goo
hidden in his grave and is coat in
another grave and his eye patch in
another grave and his gun in another
grave feels like that's too many graves
for just one outfit oh I got these all
over the place you know dead men need
options thanks for watching and if
you've made it this far why not keep the
party going with our musical guide to
all the best that guy character actors
click the thumbnail on the right to
watch now
I know you are but what am I I feel like
a little boy has lost his first tooth
put on his pillow waiting for the tooth
fair to come only two evil burglars have
crept into my window snatched it before
she could get here wait a second do you
understand the concept of the tooth
fairy